blues is a feeling and it is in
experience blues is about something that
happens in my life my name is Beverly
Watkins I was born here in Atlanta
Georgia in 1939 Beverly Watkins was a
pioneer for women in blues when I was
playing back in the 60s that wasn't no
female guitar players not enjoy
they said I play like a man but they're
using the wrong terminology the main
thing is because I play so good after
high school Beverley began touring with
the band piano red and the meter toads
shortly thereafter she was opening for
some of the biggest acts in music we
opened up for James Brown BB King Otis
Redding I played over two or three
thousand shoulders back in those days
the artist took time and hope each other
her hard classic blues style has evolved
over the last sixty years touring with
different bands and eventually going
solo
I never stopped when they said I should
I didn't pay him no mind I kept going
yes it has gotten hard out there you
know I clean houses I worked at car
washes I clean offices but I never
stopped playing my music
and she has no plans on stopping anytime
soon
well into her 70s she still puts on a
show for the crowd
it is keeping me living keeping me gon
look good and have a good time and get
up there and do my thing